la crise de la vache folle revisitait à
l'instant grâce à ce documentaire
réalisé par Sonia Gonzalez et tirée de
la série les mensonges de l'histoire ou
comment vous venez de le voir après de
longues années de désinformation de
silence ou de mensonges par omission les
autorités britanniques finiront par
avouer que la maladie de la vache folle
serait transmissible à l'homme
provoquant l'effet d'une bombe de quoi
s'interroger sur l'évolution des risques
sanitaires face au spectre d'une
pandémie c'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débat doc en commençant
par vous Clo des vins bienvenue vous
avez été ministre de la Santé entre 1988
et 1991 dans le gouvernement de Michel
Rocard puis directeur de l'agence
régionale de santé d'Île-de-France et
vous êtes aujourd'hui avocat au barreau
de Paris Christine rusion est également
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes médecin
professeur émérite en virologie à la
Faculté René Descartes c'est à l'hôpital
Necker à Paris bien entendu et membre de
l'Académie nationale de médecine et de
l'Académie nationale de pharmacie Clos
des vins 1988
1991 on voit déjà des bovins on l'a vu
d'ailleurs dans ce documentaire souffrir
de cette maladie outrement c'est ce que
vous en entendez parler au sein de votre
ministère et si oui comment
je n'entends parler mais en fin de
manière assez limité en fait faut se
souvenir que 88 91 nous sommes
confrontés au sida la montée du sida
pendant très longtemps
cela a été ignoré d'ailleurs intéressant
parce que bon c'est très caractéristique
le documentaire que nous venons de voir
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il y a une
opposition entre l'intérêt économique et
l'intérêt de santé publique peut y avoir
d'autres obstacles à l'appréhension des
questions de santé publique et moi j'ai
été confronté à
cette difficulté en 1988 où le sida au
regard des modes des modalités de
transmission relation sexuelle
homosexualité transmission par
contamination de toxicomanie tout ça
faisait que la prise en compte de ce que
représentait la contamination était
ignorée et il a fallu du temps pour
qu'effectivement il y ait une prise de
conscience alors pour revenir à la
vachement se souvient du vous arrivez
juste après le scandale du sang
contaminé qu'on a eu d'ailleurs à
traiter récemment dans cette émission
à notre sujet parce que je voulais
savoir vous n'avez pas eu un contact
avec votre homologue britannique à
l'époque qui lui-même pouvait peut-être
s'inquiéter de son côté
le cas je n'ai pas eu de contact et dans
les réunions européennes puisque nous
avions effectivement des réunions de
ministres de la santé c'est pas du tout
un sujet qui qui est venu à ce moment-là
ce n'est que beaucoup plus tard qu'il y
a eu cette cette prise de conscience
avec y compris des décisions d'ailleurs
que la France a du fait un peu plus tard
en tous les cas que la France a dû
prendre ce qui concerne l'importation de
de viande venant de Grande-Bretagne mais
c'était un sujet dont nous avions
connaissant nous commencions à avoir
connaissance par des informations mais
sans que cela soit pour le moment tous
les cas ministères de la Santé à ce
moment-là quelque chose qui était
prioritaire en tous les cas alors vous
n'avez pas eu à le faire
mais à l'époque on a appelé à manger du
bœuf français évidemment la différencier
de celui de nos voisins britanniques
rassuré les concitoyens à propos de
cette fameuse crise de lavage folle
qu'est-ce que vous en êtes tirez de
comme le son de cette crise de la vache
folle de la manière dont elle a été
gérée
j'ai trouvé que ça commence à comprendre
à quel point les données scientifiques
peuvent manquer les connaissances
peuvent manquer et là il faut se rendre
compte surtout en comparaison avec
l'épidémie de sens Cove 2 là on était
face en plus un nouveau micro-organisme
qu'on ne connaissait pas du tout cette
protéine infectieuse c'est un phénomène
extraordinairement différent de tout ce
qu'on avait comme connaissance donc
c'est vrai que scientifiquement c'était
quelque chose de totalement nouveau et
totalement incompréhensible alors il y
avait évidemment ce travail de gaz
douche qui vont très bien que la
consommation
le courant en Guyane avec la
consommation de cerveau par les femmes
et par les enfants était sans doute liée
à ces maladies neurologérer natives mais
c'est quand même ça ne les prosine heure
qui a mis en évidence le prion ça a
quand même été un décalage et encore une
fois c'est complètement nouveau par
rapport à ce qu'on vit maintenant on est
aussi face à des virus nouveau mais de
classe de virus que l'on connaît quand
même un peu ils ont en commun ces virus
auxquels on a à faire face
aujourd'hui alors évidemment la covid et
on y reviendra c'est assez longuement
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle
les homoses c'est à dire sans ces virus
qui se transmettent de l'animal à
l'homme et puis certains virus se
transmet ensuite de l'homme à l'homme
alors mais c'est vrai que la covid on en
reparlera
Ébola chikungunya la variole du singe
tout récemment c'est exactement le le
même processus sur le le plan
scientifique c'est un virus qui se
transmet
de l'animal à l'homme oui alors on est
capable de mettre d'établir une
prévention digne de ce nom pour ce type
de maladie auquel on semble de plus en
plus avoir faire face et auquel les
responsables politiques à leur poste
sont aussi aussi de plus en plus
confrontés alors disons que ces
recherches chez l'animal sont pas
forcément les mieux financés enfin j'en
suis bien convaincu et les vétérinaires
savent nous le dire mais malgré tout on
a quand même des réseaux de santé
vétérinaire qui surveille vraiment bien
la circulation des virus animaux
responsables de zones et pour ce qui
concerne les chauves-souris
ça a émergé avec la maladie covid mais
il y a eu des études très récentes qui
ont bien montré que il y a encore un
paquet de ces virus qui qui continue à
circuler chez les chauves-souris
notamment dans les grottes du Laos il y
a un papier de l'Institut Pasteur du
Laos qui est très intéressant où ils ont
été étudier les éléments de fin des des
chauves-souris et il y a plusieurs
espèces de chauves-souris qui vivent en
même temps dans les mêmes grottes parce
que il y a la nourriture qui est proche
qui est la même et du coup les échanges
de virus se font et donc on retrouve
chez ses chauves-souris ces virus très
très proches du sarce of 2 avec des
virus qui sont mosaïques et donc on a
encore un réservoir de virus qui est
prêt à nous atteindre non négligeable
les lanceurs d'alerte ce sont les
scientifiques
le responsable politique lui d'une
certaine manière l'autre bout de la
chaîne en tous les cas moi je maintiens
que les scientifiques jouent un rôle
important il appartient effectivement
aux politiques d'apprécier des
informations qui lui sont transmises par
les scientifiques et c'est vrai que le
politique il peut parfois choisir on le
voit d'ailleurs dans le documentaire
entre plusieurs intérêts moi je
considère si un ministre de la santé que
naturellement l'intérêt de la santé
publique doit primer sur tout autre
intérêt mais je reconnais que dans débat
politique il peut y avoir des
oppositions il peut y avoir des
contradictions la responsabilité du
politique c'est effectivement de choisir
mais c'est aussi d'organiser les choses
et ce que vous dites et de ce point de
vue intéressant sur le rôle
effectivement que joue des transmissions
si je puis dire de l'animal à l'homme et
on a de plus en plus et ça c'est une
décision politique effectivement si on a
de plus en plus nécessité de prendre en
considération la santé dans son ensemble
à ce qu'on dit souvent c'est une seule
santé c'est-à-dire que la santé c'est
pas uniquement la santé humaine c'est
aussi la santé animale et c'est aussi la
santé environnementale on voit de plus
en plus qu'il y a des interactions entre
ces différents abords de sujets qui a
priori peuvent apparaître très
différents mais qui ont une très forte
implication les uns sur les autres on
vient de voir avec la covid
effectivement influence d'animaux au
départ vraisemblablement qu'on transmis
à l'homme etc puis on voit aussi en
termes de santé environnementale on sait
très bien par exemple quand je dirigeais
l'agence régionale de santé nous avons
le dire très bien identifier que la
mortalité enfin les taux de morbidité en
bordure des axes routiers les plus
importants étaient plus élevés que dans
d'autres territoires de l'Île-de-France
par exemple donc on sait très bien qu'il
y a une influence environnementale sur
les tas de santé de la population mais
il y a aussi une influence de la santé
animale enfin de la transmission
effectivement de l'animal à l'homme donc
on a besoin d'avoir une appréhension
plus globale donc c'est de la
responsabilité politique d'avoir cette
démarche mais par rapport à une
situation de crise comme on l'a connu
d'ailleurs avec la covid il est
nécessaire que les scientifiques
puissent jouer un rôle important pour
éclairer la décision politique il
appartient aux politiques de décider
mais en tenant compte effectivement de
la vie qui est formulé par les
scientifiques il semble exister un
consensus aujourd'hui du côté des
scientifiques pour ce concept one Elf la
santé unique vous venez de citer alors
c'est vrai que vous l'avez dit c'est
c'est la santé des animaux et celle des
hommes sont indépendantes
interdépendantes et si l'on étudie et
protège la santé des animaux protège
l'homme également et inversement ça
c'est une voix où il y a une il y a tout
de même un consensus une voie de
recherche bien entendu et de prévention
qui fait à peu près consensus au sein
des scientifiques aujourd'hui
complètement maintenant on est tout à
fait d'accord avec ça avec une dimension
du rôle du climat et de l'évolution dans
la mesure où
rôle de la déforestation le rôle de la
ridicule par exemple
l'épidémie de Sars of 2
assez vide parmi les cervidés au Canada
et donc il a fallu comprendre mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe pour quoi les
serres en sont autant porteurs de ce
virus en fait ils allaient de plus en
plus vers les maisons le long des
villages et ils ont été en contact avec
avec la population donc on a beaucoup de
recherches à faire dans le sens homme
animal animal homme inter espèces on a
beaucoup d'adresses et puis on a
recherché par exemple pour ce qui
concerne ces virus ces coronavirus quels
sont toutes les espèces animales à
risque les rats les rats des villes
Paris New York on est play il y a plein
de rats et du coup on trouve du virus
dans les eaux usées facilement mais on
voit bien que c'est
réservoirs de virus existent y compris
dans les grandes villes donc on a toute
la vie sociale qui interagit
fait que la vie animale que ce soit des
animaux domestiques soit des animaux
d'élevage ou que ce soit des animaux
sauvages et donc il y a un ensemble de
recherches et de prévention maintenant
en recherche vétérinaire qui va être
mieux financé
c'est vrai qu'à l'occasion de la crise
de la covid
moi je crois que les scientifiques je le
disais tout à l'heure jouent un rôle
important et qu'il appartient aussi
autopolitique de décider une fine et je
ne pense pas d'ailleurs que dans la
période que nous avons connue ou dans
les périodes que nous avons connues le
politique s'est réfugié derrière des
scientifiques pour prendre telle ou
telle décision il avait besoin d'être
éclairé mais les scientifiques y compris
d'ailleurs à des niveaux parfois très
importants on oublie par exemple que
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
l'OMS l'OMS au tout début était réservé
sur le port du masque par exemple bon et
donc alors je veux dire c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de de traiter effectivement
l'ensemble des des périodes que nous
avons vécues de manière trop trop ciblée
mais
là il y a eu un conseil scientifique qui
on était face et un bossius disait tout
à l'heure je crois que c'était important
on était face à une situation nouvelle
il fallait comprendre ce qui se passait
et ça a été très vite naturellement
entre la Chine fin 2019 octobre 2019 et
le le fait que on se mobilise en France
en février mars en fait
et je pense effectivement que face à une
situation nouvelle si on veut prendre
des décisions assez rapidement et en
fait on les a pris quand même assez
rapidement en France mais il faut qu'il
y ait un éclairage scientifique et qui
puisse effectivement objectiver les
choses quoi parce qu'on a bien vu y
compris pendant cette période de crise
combien on voyait aussi des pseudos
scientifiques ou en tous les cas des
personnalités qui s'exprimaient sans
légitimité particulière sinon peut-être
leur cursus personnel l'intérêt d'un
conseil scientifique c'est quand même
qu'il y avait une confrontation
collective et que plusieurs
à bord scientifiques pouvaient échanger
se confronter et exprimer un point de
vue majoritaire pas nécessairement
unanime d'ailleurs il a pas toujours été
unanime le conseil scientifique et c'est
ça qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir quand on
est en décideur politique quel est votre
regard sur ce qui ont été les alertes du
monde scientifique
et puis les décisions politiques qui ont
été prises à l'occasion de cette crise
de la covid je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec le fait que c'est facile de refaire
le match après le match mais et que on
n'a pas fini d'entendre un certain
nombre de bêtises et de mauvaise
analyses
aujourd'hui Agnès Buzyn c'est toujours
dernier dit bon on savait en janvier on
savait j'ai essayé de prendre
rendez-vous avec le chef de l'État
Emmanuel Macron
c'est compliqué sa situation je pense
que
c'est pas c'est pas si simple et que
elle est elle est exprime sa défense
qu'autre chose plus que la réalité et
puis à ses souvenirs et puis donc voilà
je commenterai pas les arguments
scientifiques
étaient pas tant que ça pris en compte à
ce moment-là conseil scientifique
n'hésitez pas donc mais bon ce que je
pense surtout c'est que on a un résultat
aujourd'hui extrêmement intéressante
c'est le résultat qui d'un papier
récemment paru dans Nature human bifior
qui
analyse les l'évolution de l'espérance
de vie dans différents pays en Europe en
Europe centrale aux États-Unis et qui
montre que finalement la France est un
des pays sur lequel pour lesquels
l'espérance de vie a le moins diminué et
où on a le meilleur rattrapage sur
l'année 2022 et ça je pense que c'est le
résultat de politique de système de
santé publique qui a été soutenue le
pays qui a la pire situation c'est la
Bulgarie où on voit que il y avait moins
de 40% de la population vaccinée qui
avait pas de système de santé pas
d'oxygéniothérapie pas d'hospitalisation
donc vous voyez le résultat complet de
l'ensemble des mesures qui ont été
prises par les politiques que ce soit
les mesures thérapeutiques
la mise en place de l'oxygénothérapie et
autres traitement malgré les difficultés
quand ils les hospitaux finalement la
France se situe vraiment dans les pays
qui ont les meilleurs résultats
infiniment et donc je pense que
ça va changer un petit peu les discours
des uns et des autres quand ils vont
commencer à prendre en compte ces
résultats le virus certes domine c'est
lui qui gagne la partie toujours c'est
lui qui passe les il a pas de frontières
mais mais comme il a été dit la société
elle-même a réagi la société a mis son
masque la société a accepté le
confinement tout ça a fait que chaque
pays a eu une politique différente et
les résultats des courses c'est vraiment
c'était ce calcul d'espérance de vie qui
nous conforte alors moi j'en ai un qui
est de résultat c'est le nombre de
victimes aussi
tu peux être à commenter également dans
le monde 6,5 millions de personnes sont
décédées à les suites
de la covid aux États-Unis un tout petit
peu plus d'un million de personnes sont
décédées au Brésil 687
000 personnes et en France 152 000
personnes sont décédées chiffres à
octobre 2022
de ce virus
alors là il fallait réagir dans
l'urgence mais elle a vu de ces chiffres
on est face à une pandémie qui a pas
forcément été très très bien géré vu le
nombre de victimes malgré tout Claude et
je suis désolé parce que ce que Madame
Rosio vient d'évoquer au contraire
montre que la France a plutôt pas mal
géré quand on se compare et au regard de
publication récentes que Madame rosou
vient d'évoquer les fesses parce qu'il
faut apprécier ça sur le long terme et
notamment l'espérance de vie que l'on
peut effectivement constater donc 2022
et le rattrapage montre quand même que
comparativement à d'autres pays y
compris d'Europe proche je pense que par
exemple vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne alors
qu'on a souvent été comparé à
l'Allemagne au regard de du fait qu'il y
avait plus de livres réanimation en
Allemagne etc qu'il a aussi est une
mauvaise polémique parce que on ne
compte pas les mêmes choses bon donc peu
importe mais non on a donc effectivement
mais là je me réfère aux scientifiques
c'est une publication scientifique
récente qui montre que la politique qui
a été menée enfin que le résultat je
veux dire c'est pas une appréciation sur
la politique que le résultat en termes
d'expérience de vie à est meilleur en
France que dans bien d'autres pays
européens proche de nous donc non je
crois que effectivement dans une crise
il y a des polémiques il y en a
malheureusement
encore aujourd'hui bon voilà on évite
pas bon il appartient aux politiques de
pouvoir prendre des décisions malgré des
polémiques et de les prendre notamment
éclairé par les scientifiques puisque
c'est un des éléments du débat justement
non mais ces chiffres pour montrer
l'ampleur
en Grande-Bretagne 27 en France en tout
cas ceux qui ont été considérés comme
mort dû à cette fameuse crise de de la
vache folle ce qui change c'est qu'on a
été obligé de gérer une une épidémie
dans l'urgence oui je pense que de toute
façon les chiffres sont je dirais à
moitié faux voir au moins un carrefour
les estimations sont bien supérieures à
ça dans un certain nombre de pays où la
mortalité est malestimée où on sait pas
on sait pas de quoi les gens sont morts
c'est à dire qu'il faut des tests pour
dire il est mort du covid il est mort
avec les signes du covid donc
je voulais vous amener on est quand même
avec une sous-estimation très importante
y compris aux États-Unis il faut quand
même relativiser ce qu'il n'y ait pas
totalement en France puisque
progressivement maintenant d'ailleurs on
voit bien dans les courbes de santé
publique France que l'on différencie
dans la mortalité actuelle les morts du
covid et le delta qui est lié à d'autres
pathologies sachant que chez les
personnes âgées c'est pas facile de
savoir si c'est parce que son état de
faiblesse est tel que elle a pas pu
réagir à covid et qu'elle est-ce qu'elle
est morte de fait de vieillesse ou
est-ce qu'il manque de covid donc voyez
c'est difficulté de comptabilité et
elles sont quand même assez importantes
mais c'est vrai que l'urgence
il y a une un moment assez difficile et
le Conseil Scientifique l'a beaucoup
rappelé c'est le moment où cette
mortalité dans les hésitez pas dans les
EHPAD n'a pas été si bien prévenu et moi
je suis pas mal en contact avec le
groupe des EHPAD du Groupe SOS et je
dois avouer que à ce moment-là on est
beaucoup intervenu pour inciter au
lavage des mains l'isolement des gens et
c'est sûr que les personnes âgées mais
mais c'était compliqué de de d'un dieu
de faire la révolution des mesures
d'hygiène complètes dans ces dans ces
EHPAD avec la de ménage on fait
attention au plateau on le dépose à la
porte mais la femme de ménage elle
arrive et elle vient elle touche à tout
donc voyez c'était il y a eu cette
période qui a été difficile sur ce
terrain de l'urgence parce que la
prévention évidemment plus on l'a plus
plus on prévient moi on a besoin de
guérir là on était dans une forme
d'urgence qui obligeait les responsables
politiques à prendre des décisions dans
l'urgence
c'est surtout ça qui aura marqué durant
cette gestion de la pandémie dans
l'urgence alors on peut se dire
effectivement après qu'il aurait fallu
prendre certaines décisions plutôt plus
vite naturellement sans doute sans doute
des janvier en tous les cas
vraisemblablement même enfin je fais
pas beaucoup de cas on n'avait pas
beaucoup de cas les premiers cas arrive
fin janvier mais on commençait à voir
des des informations enfin qui
semblaient arriver quand même de Chine à
l'époque enfin tous les cas bon février
que vraiment on a commencé à avoir
l'alerte je trouve oui mais alors il
fallait effectivement sans doute prendre
des décisions plutôt je rappelle quand
même trouver aussi le bon discours
vis-à-vis de l'opinion pour le recours
je rappelle quand même qu'à l'époque et
les personnalités qui parfois ont assumé
les responsabilités ensuite disait que
c'était une grippette et qu'il n'y avait
pas lieu de s'inquiéter
au contraire on voit bien quand même que
cette par des mises est une pandémie
mortelle moins moins grave même si
malheureusement c'est toujours très
grave quand il y a autant de décès que
moins grave peut-être que dans d'autres
pays mais c'était quand même mortel et
c'était quand même on a bien vu après
alors il y a eu de la part de ces
personnalités parfois quand même
rectifiées rectification du discours
ensuite mais on avait quand même au
départ des gens qui nous disaient que
c'était une grippette et qui avait pas
lieu de s'inquiéter bon alors après
c'est vrai qu'il y avait des décisions à
prendre qui n'étaient pas simples non
plus à prendre et effectivement par
exemple début mars la veille des
élections municipales 2020 on voyait
bien que si les six le gouvernement s'y
avait pris la décision de reporter les
municipales il y a une polémique sur le
refus de la démocratie sur l'inquiétude
que pouvait avoir la majorité face à des
résultats qu'il aurait pu la mettre en
difficulté etc donc la décision
politique est toujours compliquée à
prendre et quand je dis ça je ne mets
pas de la décision politique
naturellement je crois que je crois
beaucoup à la décision politique ce que
je veux dire par là c'est qu'il y a
toujours plusieurs éléments à prendre en
considération et que naturellement moi
je crois que l'intérêt de la de la santé
publique l'intérêt de la population doit
primer mais je reconnais qu'il peut y
avoir d'autres
abords de la décision politique la porte
de sortie pour la majorité des crises
sanitaires qui nous préoccupent dans
cette émission c'est le vaccin parce que
sans le vaccin on aurait peut-être pas
vu la fin de d'un certain nombre de
pandémie a commencé par la covid bien
entendu oui ça a été assez
extraordinaire ces vaccins à RN
messagers ils étaient en préparation si
je puis dire et on essaie depuis plus de
20 ans c'était pas c'est pas sorti du
chapeau comme ça mais mais par contre
les deux firmes les trois firmes ont
quand même bien compris l'opportunité
d'utiliser cette technologie qu'il
maîtrisait pour le cancer dans un dans
l'infectiologie en infectiologie donc ça
je pense que il faut reconnaître que
c'est assez extraordinaire dans la
mesure où c'est des vaccins qui te sont
plus faciles à produire qui sont
totalement adaptés puisqu'on avait les
séquences virales on savait exactement
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait mettre dans ses
vaccins et puis on savait les construire
avec ces nanoparticules de lipides on
savait dégrader les ARN messager pour
être sûr de pas induire trop d'effets
secondaires
que l'on avait vécu dans le dans le
cancer donc c'est vrai que c'est des
vaccins plus facile à produire c'est
vrai qu'on a eu vraiment beaucoup de
chance que
que ce soit se développements a été
assez important
pas quand même investi aussi plus de 30
milliards pour développer les usines
enfin il y a eu quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de prises en charge de
développement de la production parce que
il y a pas le tout de d'avoir un vaccin
il faut aussi les produire et on voit
bien que les Chinois et les Russes ont
pris des voix tellement classiques que
face à cette infection qui induit une
immunité finalement modeste puis qui
diminue dans le temps était beaucoup
trop faible pour les vaccins novovax et
les vaccins chinois alors les campagnes
de vaccination elles ont pas toutes
connues un grand succès et il y a le
virus H1 qui était suite à une grippe
aviaire
on peut dire les choses comme ça je
crois et
eroser une Bachelot à l'époque où nous
sommes à après les années 2005 entre
2005 et 2009 2010 2009 2010 là lance une
grande campagne de vaccination ça sera
un échec sanitaire dixit la commission
parlementaire qu'ensuite travailler sur
ce sujet après coup
il faut en faire trop parfois quitte à
en faire trop comme peut-être ça a été
le cas sur la c'est difficile si vous en
faites trop vous êtes accusé après avoir
fait trop et d'ailleurs ça a été un des
éléments qui a aussi
parfois retarder certaines décisions y
compris dans la période que nous vivons
mais si vous en faites pas assez vous
vous subissez aussi des critiques donc
voilà bon je veux dire c'est ça fait
partie de la décision et des risques de
la décision bon je crois qu'il faut
effectivement c'est ce qu'on a dit
évoqué à plusieurs reprises au cours de
cet échange c'est que ça nécessite
effectivement qu'il y ait un éclairage
le politique qui prend pas des décisions
au doigt pardonnez-moi cette expression
je disais au doigt mouillé il prend pas
des décisions en fonction de de tel ou
tel message qui lui est passé comme ça
venant de personnalité diverses
l'intérêt je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et
je le répète l'intérêt dans la période
que nous venons de vivre c'est d'avoir
eu un conseil scientifique qui avait une
délibération collective avec des
compétences diverses avec des avis
divers y compris qui expriment un point
de vue majoritaire qui n'est pas
nécessairement l'unan et ça c'est
important pour la décision politique le
politique sur des sujets comme celui-là
c'est lui qui prend la décision mais il
a besoin d'être éclairé il ne politique
il n'est pas il n'est pas omniscient il
n'est pas il ne connaît pas tout bon moi
quand j'étais ministre de la Santé j'ai
été confronté je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure la question du virus du sida et
on était face à une situation aussi un
peu nouvelle dans dans l'ampleur que ça
prenait ça avait malheureusement
commencé bien avant mais dans l'ampleur
que ça prenait j'ai été amené à prendre
des décisions qui parfois d'ailleurs
m'ont value quelques difficultés cours
de justice de la République par exemple
j'ai une fois mis en examen mais j'ai
pris mes décisions au regard d'un avis
scientifique qui m'était effectivement
formulé et la vie scientifique qui peut
parfois ne pas correspondre à ce qui est
attendu médiatiquement et les polémiques
que l'on voit apparaître médiatiquement
ne sont pas tout à fait conformes à la
pointe d'appréciation scientifique et il
faut que le politique choisisse mais je
crois que le politique doit choisir en
fonction de l'intérêt alors l'intérêt
général c'est difficile à dire parce
qu'il y a parfois des intérêts
économiques qui s'expriment qui sont
aussi des erreurs
dans la question si j'étais confronté
que la question de la lutte contre
l'alcoolisme c'est vrai que par exemple
il y avait un intérêt qui intéresse des
producteurs de 20 et je crois qu'il faut
prendre effectivement en considération
mais pour un ministre de la Santé ce qui
prime c'est la santé publique
concernant les connaissances en janvier
février il faut aussi rappeler que les
épis de mes épidémies de de sarce et de
mars avaient pas du tout induit une
mortalité aussi forte qu'elles étaient
éteinte d'elle-même et qui plus est il
faut rappeler que il n'y avait pas les
informations de la Chine concernant la
mortalité réelle de ce virus absolument
et donc c'est des grosses incertitudes
qui ont enfin qui ont aussi
été débattus abondamment où on disait
qui exclusait certains qui disaient la
grippette c'était pas une grippette mais
ça avait pas tant tué que ça dans les
deux autres virus virus enfin
coronavirus précédente et donc voilà
est-ce que celui-là va être beaucoup
plus méchant
ne nous donnait pas l'information alors
qu'elle l'avait puisqu'elle confinait
déjà largement ce fameux temps de
latence
qui coûtera assez cher à l'ensemble de
la planète finalement
dans l'attente de trois semaines mais en
même temps on a quand même eu une grande
grande leçon de cette épidémie c'est que
la coopération internationale pour
l'analyse de tous les virus et des
séquences virales dans le groupe guised
a été extrêmement important et ensuite
en temps réel encore maintenant tous ces
virus et il faut que les suivre au plan
international bon le conseil
scientifique a été dissout et le
remplace aujourd'hui le covars le comité
de Vald et d'anticipation des risques
sanitaires et il va être il a été mis en
place par François Braun l'actuel le
ministre de la Santé il comprend 19
membres quelle est la mission de ce
nouveau comité elle est beaucoup plus
large elle est pas bien sûr il commence
par leur premier communiqué concerne le
covid mais c'est beaucoup plus large ça
va être sur les risques sanitaires au
sens large
bien sûr ils vont commencer par les
risques épidémiques et mais j'ai vu
Brigitte Autrand encore récemment
ils ont beaucoup beaucoup de travail
parce que leur mission a été vraiment
très élargi par rapport
au Conseil Scientifique précédent qui
concernait que cet été finalement ils
sont très peu alors je ne sais pas mais
l'équivalent en Grande-Bretagne
s'appelle le sage je crois c'est plus de
1000 personnes qui travaillent à
l'intérieur de ce comité est-ce qu'on
n'est pas un peu sous-dimensionné dans
ce type de communauté aujourd'hui en
France avec ce commerce qui vient de
prendre la page du conseil scientifique
n'a pas servi pour la restructuration
des différents services en France
c'est-à-dire que il y a la santé et la
santé publique France il y a la chasse
il y a un certain nombre de comme ça de
d'unités qui ont des rôles et qui
travaillent pas tant que ça en lien
c'est vrai que le comité des sages a
beaucoup plus de personnes et beaucoup
plus de chercheurs et le système de
surveillance est quand même a été bien
meilleur en Angleterre
le covars
est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut
attendre une meilleure prévention en
amont pour prévenir plutôt que guérir
comme ça a été le cas avec la covid il y
a plusieurs aspects quand on parle de
prévention là en l'occurrence ce qui est
plutôt à mettre en évidence et à
nécessiter d'avoir une alerte à ce que
effectivement
comme ça vient d'être évoqué nous
n'avions pas toutes les informations la
Chine était assez assez jalouse enfin si
je puis dire pour faire un trésor
naturellement quant aux informations
qu'elles auraient acceptées de diffuser
donc c'est d'avoir un système d'alerte
ça fait partie de la prévention mais il
y a d'autres d'autres démarches de
prévention des préventions qui sont
liées à l'appréhension qu'on peut avoir
de telle ou tel risque environnemental
et dont on se prémunit le principe de
précaution que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure fait aussi partie de la démarche
de prévention donc effectivement
ça nécessite effectivement d'avoir une
une démarche très très large alors en
effet le covar est limité quand son
nombre de personnes moi je suis aussi
tout à fait sensible à la nécessité
qu'il y ait de d'une bonne articulation
avec d'autres organismes qui peuvent
exister même si d'autres organismes
aussi d'autres missions qui ne sont pas
du tout qui ne rentrent pas
nécessairement dans l'émission du covars
d'autre part j'espère que je pense
d'ailleurs que ce comité le covars
s'appuiera aussi sur des scientifiques
qui existent on a quand même en France
la chance d'avoir des réseaux de
scientifiques qui sont compétents qui
sont présents sur la scène
internationale qui sont sensibles à ce
qui peut s'effectivement se passer dans
tel ou tel pays et qui par ailleurs
publient et ont des des réflexions
approfondie et qui pourront être utiles
en effet pour éclairer les avis que
formulera ce comité merci un grand merci
à tous les deux devoir participé à ce
débat doc aujourd'hui pour parler de les
politiques de prévention des risques
sanitaires et surtout des risques
épidémiques puisque c'était au centre de
notre
échange aujourd'hui dans ce débat doc
après ce documentaire consacré à la
fameuse crise de la vache folle vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
sur Twitter merci à celle massali qui
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission et
puis je vous donne tout simplement
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien entendu avec son
documentaire et son débattre à très
bientôt
[Musique]